[Music]
meme
review
[Music]
wait a second it's flat what the flip
kind of want these conspiracy theorists
to get a win not gonna lie
wait you're in love with me always have
been
that's so sweet that's so nice wholesome
wait you didn't even throw this stick
i never did i never do
do bad do by do by do by do subscribe
thanks for watching this video i'm sorry
welcome to meme review always has been
greatest meme of all time wait it's all
detroit
always has been hold up where's your gun
can i have in detroit omegle talk
to strangers wait it's old peepee
yeah don't go on omegle bros
don't go there they're doing over there
wait earth is round yeah i thought it
was flat
dumbass that's right there must be some
i can't believe the suit is hacking my
eyes there's no way
wait it's all schizophrenia what
it's not all usa never has been
shut up alien wait the dinner isn't
ready
it never works now set the table
wait it's all safe it always been
wait guns are ineffective in space due
to the lack of oxygen for the gun power
to burn
always has been can't shoot me
the sun is biker blast the sun is back a
blessed
i knew it honestly this is my biggest
theory
it's not a png never had been don't you
just love when a picture has this in the
background you save it and it's not a
png
so you have to cut out this background
anyway so you wonder why the
did you upload this me too me too
this town ain't big enough for the two
of us never has been
always has been
it's all rango from 2011
[Music]
i knew it i knew it
i want a full feature film of this
it captures art in its finest form
it always has been
[Music]
of course there's a pickle rick one it's
always been
[Applause]
[Music]
started being funny real fast didn't it
you felt that you felt that at the same
time
yep well we had something for a little
while
ah cyronic will deliver for sure
wait it's all astronaut
[Music]
nice see that's a clever twist
no you can't just replace with a random
meme in the meme just to make it a meme
you have to make it interesting and
clever and subvert your expectation to
actually make me laugh haha pickle rick
though
take a ring wait it's all a gif
always has been
a continue
pretty impressive for a gift not
off god damn it
it's just like can it just stop i don't
know why
why out of all memes do you have to live
i thought i killed you ages ago i guess
i never reviewed
rickroll i'm coming for you ass boy
i'm coming for you wait your girl always
have been
get it because samus is a girl wait it's
all soup
always has been i watch code gas and i
don't understand this meme
is it the one where the man stands in
front and you can't really see him
no all right i don't get it are you
winning son
always have been dead yeah
yeah wait is all football
john madden john madden what the
wait it's me
you're my world bro
that's a good one
it's all berries and then we got this
and then we have that wait it's all toys
always has bro um
you made the joke huh how do you feel do
you feel good about yourself now
always has been meme it was a fun ride
wasn't it i'm gonna have to do it
i'm gonna have to give it a three point
four
five six eight nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen fourteen fifty six detective
reveal next meme god damn it oh
[Music]
i don't know i never played it rainbow
six i funny
nice i don't know i never played it yeah
i never played it either that could be
it
i don't care detroit when it becomes
human i don't know i don't believe
elder scrolls or something i don't know
i play the games
get it because it's an old man and he's
scrolling
get it get it you don't get it but
i got it before you got it
i never played elder scrolls hearthstone
or something
hearthstone i don't know i never played
game no man's sky
oh we're getting real clever up in here
seriously
two next meme don't waste my goddamn
time
so jack versus chad memes oh other game
leagues haha this character dies in five
hours
no sonic leaves this game will be
we know we know
yes i quite like this meme format it
make me go haha that's funny
fictional dystopia everything is
controlled by corporations and the
government want its people
dead no real dystopia everything is
controlled by corporations
and the government wants its people dead
we know
it is what it is america
this historical figure did one bad thing
by today's standard
this cancels all the good he did we must
tear down the statues
now everywhere else this medieval king
was a piece of
with zero redeemable qualities even by
the standards of his time
we know let's name some more places
after him
he was awesome movie leagues the
character dies no
radiation leaks
nice got it it's a different type of
leaks
got it i got it i understand the joke so
funny i'm laughing inside
girls is my handwriting good yeah but
you can still make it
better boys what did you write here i
don't know
i don't know either help me
pc gamers your pc sucks no
laptop gamers your laptop sucks i know
yeah
goddamn gaming laptops i don't get it
i don't get it every goddamn time i you
lean your hand here on a gaming laptop
and it burns up can they put some
material
here mr gaming laptop manufacturers
to make it not make my wrist burn up
because i tend to play with the wasd
i don't know if you heard about that
let's make gaming laptop oh should we
make
comfortable for gamers no
so true modern literature reader haha
the author said
she didn't like trans people no classic
literature reader he hated black people
jews and women
i know i feel like i understand the
argument but i feel like it depends on
the medium
and how it exists in their literature
if that makes sense i feel like like
music
and books i i guess novels especially is
so distant from the author
at least in in my opinion i don't really
care what they did
as long as they didn't murder someone
and as long as it doesn't reflect their
literature who cares
chad versus sorry jack gets a four i got
a couple good chuckles
what do you think what would you rate
hey remember when uh mark zuckerberg
became such a massive
meme online because he looked like a
robot and then
it became such a big deal that
zuckerberg just disappeared from the
internet
well this just in zuckerberg still looks
like a robot
this is himself my man you look like
data
my man you look like data from star trek
i guess nothing new on mark zuckerberg
front feels good to know at that at
least
please check in in another six month
mark zuckerberg
can't wait to see is it me
or is mark zuckerberg packing dude
hell yeah hell yeah next meme
it's not really a meme but you've
probably seen these they've gone viral
like crazy
it's a toilet paper what
no difference i ate my toilet paper the
same way
oh great it's a cake got it color me and
pressed
oh my god
why why would you do that
[Applause]
the happy music makes it feel so
spiteful
you know what i mean like yeah i know
what i just did to you yeah i know that
it's not a
off for coffee your strawberry
oh come on dude
oh even the plate why am i so annoyed by
these
my god stop it
[Music]
stop oh my god
hey look vegetarians can eat steak now
how about that that's great
i hate it i hate it so much oh my god
it's fuzzy there's no way you can cut
that
it's fuzzy everything oh
okay all right
but why why did you do this if dad walks
in right now ask if i'm winning no
no i'm not i'm watching cake
videos i'm not winning dan
come back in 20 minutes when i'm done
with this you won't believe what this
cakes
is real unbelievable it's not a cake
can you believe it's not a cake it's not
a cake
it's not a cake this cake ah
it's not a cake pewdiepie controller
not the cake what
microphone is it cake
always has been get it i did the joke
from before and it didn't really work
but i did it anyway
thank you for watching meme review see
you next time
fellow memesters remember to dab on them
haters
and eat your mama's taters good joke all
right
bye god damn it ah
children of nine parts
it's time to race what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming too nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean
[Music]
foreign